قالت هيئه الدفاع عن رئيس حركه النظر راشد
الغنوشي ان المحكمه الابتدائيه قضت بسجنه
لمده عام على خلفيه دعوى تقدم بها احد
عناصر النقابات الامنيه اتهم فيها الغنوشي
بانه وصف رجال الامن بالطواغيت كان ذاك
خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما
خلفيات وحيفيات الحكم على رئيس حركه
النهضه ورئيس البرلمان السابق بالسجن لمده
عام وفي اي سياق ياتي الحكم بسجن الغنوشي
وما مدى ارتباطه بما شهدته تونس من
اعتقالات سياسيه وما هي الانعكاسات
المحتمله لهذا الحكم على المشهدين السياسي
والاجتماعي في تونس
اجيبك بطريقه قانونيه سليمه باعتبار محامي
انا المتهم الذي يحكم كما هو الحال
بالنسبه للسيد راشد الغنوشي غيابيا لانه
رفض الحضور له الحق في الاعتراض ثم الحق
في درجه ثانيه في الاستئناف ثم في التعقيب
ولو الحق حتى في التماس اعاده النظر
وتحميل قوانين الدوليه واذا كان بريئا
يمكن له حتى ان يدور قضيه ولكن لا يمكن
باي حال من الاحوال الاجابه خلاص او
للمعارضين ان يستغلوا هذه الفرص لتكييف
على اساس ان نظام ديكتاتوري القضيه فيها
جانب قانوني وفيها جانب سياسي الجانب
القانوني يظهر خاصه في الاخلالات
الاجرائيه الكبيره التي شهدتها هذه القضيه
لعل اهم خلل اجرائي شهدت هذه القضيه انها
الاستاذ راشد الغنوشي يقع محاكمته بالغياب
ورغم طلب الدفاع تاجيل القضيه وتاجيل
النظر فيها الا ان هيئه المحكمه رفضت
تاجيل من مقرها هيئه الدفاع لمقاطعه هذه
الجلسه وعدم ايضا من جهه المضمون ما صرح
به الاستاذ راشد الغنوشي كان في تابين
لاحد المتوفين من
المنخرطي حركه النهضه وهذا سياق ديني وقع
استعمال فيه مصطلحات دينيه موجوده في
القران الكريم وموجوده في الثقافه العربيه
والاسلاميه
طاغوت انه يخشى الله سبحانه وتعالى للاسف
في اليوم يقع التغاضي على خمسين سنه من
ارثه الفكري والسياسي ويقع توجيه تهمه له
مضحكه لا يمكن ان يصدقها اي احد في العالم
كيف يمكن ان نصدق ان الاستاذ رجل الغنوشي
متهم بالتكفير
فيما يتعلق به هل يمكن ان نفهم هذه
المساله من زاويه سياسيه مرتبطه بزاويه
قانونيه وانا الانظمه تحكم بطريقه عموديه
لتسلق قضاء على وزاره العدل وزاره العدل
تقوم به الايحاء الى قضاه هذا امر ننفيه
مطلقا في تونس ولكن حقيقه الان المناخ
السياسي في البلاد واعتبار القضاء وظيفه
بمقتضى الدستور الجديد وبمقتضى التصريحات
الرسميه الصادره عن السلطه التنفيذيه وراس
السلطه السياسيه في البلاد يجعل الكثير من
الامور تحوم حول
قدره القضاء على اقامه العدل وعلى الفصل
في مثل هذه القضايا التي خلفتها خلفيتها
السياسيه اصبحت واضحه راس السلطه
التنفيذيه لا يعتبر ان القضاء سلطه وانما
يعتبرها وظيفه وهذه الوظيفه هي تحت
املاءات السلطه التنفيذيه وتخضع لسياسات
لسياسه الجزائيه للسلطه التنفيذيه
وبالتالي نحن لا نتهم القضاء بعدم
الاستقلاليه وانما
فرحت به السلطه التنفيذيه هي التي تنزعت
من هذه الاستقلاليه وهو اهم شرط من شروط
اقامه العدل بالنسبه للسلطه القضائيه والا
كيف يصدر حكم على رئيس حركه النهضه ورئيس
البرلمان في جلسه واحده لم يحضر فيها
المتهم ولم يحذى الدفاع بفرصه لتقديم حججه
وبراهين على تهافت هذه التهمه لولا ان
الحكم كان جاهزا بالمسبق
[موسيقى]
للاسف مثل هذه السياسات ومثل هذه
الاجراءات لا تساعد على خروج البلاد من
الازمه الشامله التي تعيش سواء في المستوى
السياسي او الاقتصادي والاجتماعي الان
السلطه عوض انها تعمل على
توحيد التونسيين وعلى جمعهم حول طاوله
واحده هي طويله الحوار وعلى البحث على
حلول توافقيه نستطيع من خلالها مواجهه
التحديات والمخاطر الكبيره التي تواجهها
البلاد للاسف نجد ان هذه السلطه تهرب الى
الامام وتضع راسها في الرمل وتعتقد انها
بقمح وتنكيلها بالمعارضين تستطيع ان تفرز
استقرار الامر الواقع
[موسيقى]